During a lightening storm, mass electric fields can build up between the ground and the earth.
Let's say that in one particular lightening storm, you have an electric field
of 10,000 N/C pointing downwards.
Let's say you want to take advantage of this electric field
by taking an air-filled balloon that you've recently inflated--
that's a balloon, by the way--
and rubbing it on your head, because rubbing a balloon on your head
actually causes the rubber of the balloon to strip electrons away from your hair
and give the balloon a negative charge.
By doing this, you're hoping that you can take your balloon and have it suspend itself
inside this region of electric fields in such a way that the weight of the balloon downwards
is exactly the balanced by an electric force upwards.
If we know that the weight of the balloon--or I should say the mass of the balloon--
is 30 g, how much charge must you put on the balloon to have it balance perfeclty
in this electric field? Enter your answer here in Coulombs.
I've set this up in scientific notation,
so you can enter your exponent here and the base part of your number here.